why is there so much foam wait i just
removed it and it actually worked
i actually poached an egg in mountain
dew have you ever wanted to eat
nothing but mountain dew me neither but
that's exactly what i'm going to be
doing for the next few days
this is the mountain dew cookbook it's
full of 96 recipes that all have
mountain dew in them and i'm going to be
making
only food from this cookbook i hope i
don't die
[Music]
it is far too early for mountain dew
and yet
this is my life now my first meal today
is gonna be mountain dew
pancakes they're pancakes but green so
for the pancakes themselves all you need
to do is mix mountain dew with a
complete buttermilk pancakes mix
um so that's pretty simple and as with
any pancakes you heat them on a skillet
flip them over after they bubble and
enjoy those are some pancakes right
there the real atrocity here
is the syrup which is made with carroll
oil
sugar and mountain dew i'm from vermont
i have seven bottles of real vermont
maple syrup currently
i feel like this is a personal affront
to me but you know what
the cookbook told me to do it
that's some breakfast right there some
people wake up in the morning with
coffee i wake up with
mountain dew pancakes
that syrup is very sweet tastes like
honey and i think i like it better than
fake maple syrup because it's not
trying to pretend to be maple syrup it's
its own thing
the pancakes actually are pretty fluffy
they're nice they're airy these are so
green i'm gonna go get dressed get ready
for work do a bit of work
and i will see you at lunch time after
breakfast i was feeling
very highly caffeinated and very there
was a lot of sugar
let me just say that but now it's lunch
time i'm getting a bit hungry again
i'm ready to inject some more caffeine
and sugar
into my veins i'm going to be making
grilled cheese sandwiches and these are
pretty simple all i'm going to be doing
is reducing some mountain dew mixing
that with some cheddar cheese and some
cream cheese
and then spreading that on some white
bread and toasting that bread
let's do this i've completely just made
a
like a greenish brown sludge and it's so
disgusting looking i am afraid of this
it just feels way too thin to spread
right now this looks like some witch is
brewing a cauldron of evil potion
i'm gonna try a little bite of this
cheese and see what it
tastes like oh that's really bad i think
i need to try again with a little bit
less mountain dew
and honestly a little less cream cheese
too attempt number two
a little less mountain dew i know i'm
modifying the recipe from something that
was in the cookbook but i want to
survive this challenge and i want to
enjoy myself so
i think that this will be a slightly
better version
of the grilled cheese that is in the
mountain dew cookbook
[Music]
this is so much more promising it's just
not a liquid anymore
uh so i think i will be able to actually
spread this on the bread and then toast
the bread up
and make a pretty decent grilled cheese
sandwich
[Music]
look at those bad boys those look like
good grilled cheese sandwiches if the
cheese
was green normally uh
oh my god all right
okay that's pretty good i'm glad i made
the adjustments that i did
it was definitely a little too sweet
before you don't have to follow a recipe
exactly
it's just a starting off point it looks
like shrek's usual shark
is a good lunch but that was a lot of
cheese so it's about dinner time on my
first day of eating
i'm very hungry it's pretty late in the
evening actually now tonight i'm going
to be making some chicken
i have to marinate the chicken in this
mountain dew marinade
leave it in the marinade for an hour and
then pan fry it
i'm also going to make a sauce that's
just sour cream chives and a little bit
of hot sauce
[Music]
it looks pretty good the flavor of that
marinade is very prominent
it's very limey and lemony let's try it
with a sauce
oh boy you can really taste the mountain
dew i think the marinade needed a bit of
oil and then maybe a little bit less
citrus i shouldn't be eating this this
late i'm gonna be awake all night i'm
gonna be wired on
caffeinated chicken i'll call day one a
success
the only thing that made me feel gross
was the pancakes those uh
hit me pretty hard i'm feeling good
good morning from day two dakota are
ready to eat some mountain dew
food i woke up this morning and i was
like i want a bagel and then i was like
nope you're having green eggs and ham
so this morning i'm gonna be starting
the day with green eggs and a ham it's
just poached eggs
but instead of poaching it in water you
poach it in mountain dew
i don't think gordon ramsay would
approve but you know
you gotta do what you gotta do
oh my god do you see all the foam on
this this is disgusting
this is not how you're supposed to poach
an egg why is there so
much foam
wait i just removed it and it actually
worked oh my god i can't believe it
actually worked
i actually poached an egg in mountain
dew let's put it on some ham and toast
and
try it out
okay this egg poached weirdly well
in mountain dew maybe
mountain dew is better than water for
poaching eggs
yeah it's just like a little bit sweeter
than normal poached eggs
if you like poached eggs you're gonna
like this a little bit of canadian bacon
and some toast
delicious i'm a little bummed they
didn't include a mountain dew
hollandaise sauce recipe
this will have to do the more i ate of
that the better i liked it that was a
good start to tuesday
or dues day as we call it here i'm
looking forward to the other meals i
have to make today
the big thing is i'm out of mountain dew
i gotta go get more
another box of these for lunch today i'm
actually not feeling super hungry so i'm
gonna make
some mozzarella bites these look very
tasty and very
red and they're actually coated in
flamin hot cheetos
i hope these are good because they look
good boy oh boy
i'm the picture of health you make these
by melting some mozzarella some cream
cheese and some mountain dew
[Music]
freezing that up a little bit
[Music]
and then coating it in flaming hot
cheetos and deep frying them
[Music]
these are so bright the colors on these
feel radioactive i feel like i might get
a superpower eating these
or die those are the only two options i
feel like this belongs on nickelodeon in
the 90s
all right let's try this
the cheese is kind of sweet and the
flamin hotness of the flamin hot cheetos
is no longer flaming hot
i don't dislike them
but i don't like them as with the
grilled cheese it would have been way
better had they just forgotten
the cream cheese filling just do the
mozzarella the cream cheese i feel like
is taking away from this
i wish that there was some sort of sauce
with these maybe like marinara sauce i
feel like would go really well with
these
oh i can't eat much more of those my
stomach feels something
um i think i might have to
mountain doo doo so sorry for using
those words i need some greens
and not green is in mountain dew it's
been a couple hours since i ate those
mozzarella bites and i do not feel great
so i came here to the grocery store with
the intention of buying tomatillos to
make salsa verde but the grocery store
doesn't have any tomatillos and it's the
only grocery store that's open
right now um because it's kind of late
in the evening but i also
really am not hungry those mozzarella
bites kind of made me feel sick
and so i like my stomach's kind of
feeling
and i might just not eat dinner tonight
probably not the best decision
but it's kind of what i'm feeling right
[Music]
now
do you ever wake up enjoy getting out of
bed because you know the first thing you
have to eat is jalapeno poppers wrapped
in bacon and filled with mountain dew
me too for some reason i am super tired
today like
way more tired than i ever normally am
and i'm wondering to myself like is it
because i've had so much sugar
like is that making me tired this
morning i've decided to forgo breakfast
like i usually would because i usually
kind of feel a little sick if i eat
breakfast in the morning
um and i'm going to in a little while
start making myself some lunch which is
going to be some jalapeno poppers the
first thing you got to do is marinate
the jalapenos
in mountain dew so i'm going to start by
taking out the seeds and marinating them
for an
hour then i'm going to make the cream
cheese filling and then i'm going to
make the dip which is like sour cream
mayonnaise mountain dew
and a couple other spices these aren't
the prettiest things in the world
in fact they're pretty gross looking all
the ingredients
seem like they should make something
tasty so i'm actually pretty excited to
eat these
okay these have kind of exploded inside
of the toaster oven
and the bacon isn't crisping yet i'm
gonna put them on the stove top to just
kind of crisp the bacon up a little bit
before i eat them
so these are very messy i don't really
know how to go about eating them
this one looks like the most intact
i'm just gonna go for it mmm oh that's
good this is the best thing i've had so
far the saltiness of the bacon
combined with like a little bit of the
sweetness from the the cream cheese
filling and then the jalapeno spice is
like
perfect this is a really good flavor
combo now i want to try it in this dip
which is
really liquidy okay
that dips good i mean it's not healthy
can i just
end on these because this is a high note
it is not warm in here but i'm sweating
right now
i think i have like meat sweats from
that bacon
i don't know i shouldn't have eaten all
of it that was a bad idea
do you just feel like you can't do
anything because all you've eaten for
the last two and a half days has been
mountain dew food
this is not a diet i recommend for
anyone don't do this to yourselves
dinner's in a couple hours uh and
tonight i'm making steak
but that means i have to get started now
because the only mountain dew part of
the steak is actually the sauce that
goes on it
and you gotta let that sit for a while
it is steak time hopefully the steak
goes better than my toast or steak
the recipe calls for a grilled steak but
i live in a new york city apartment and
do not have outdoor space
so i don't have a grill so i'm going to
be making this on a nice
cast iron skillet should work just fine
first i've got to rub the steak in the
dry rub and then put it on the skillet
and
hope they turn out well
let them eat steak i think that's what
marie antoinette said
right this looks incredible look at that
juicy red oh that's really good so i
coated the steak in
the dry rub dry rubs definitely work
better on a grill than in a cast iron
skillet but it worked the flavor
definitely did
get into the steak itself but you know
what the dry rub doesn't have in it
mountain dew
that's where this steak sauce comes in
there we go
i think the sauce is a little too heavy
on the oil i would probably cut the oil
content in half
this is a good steak i'm really happy
with this i'm probably going to die
of meat sweats one thing about this
cookbook is
every single entree except for the
grilled cheese
is a meat entree i don't eat very much
meat so this has been a pretty drastic
change and i think that might be part of
why i'm feeling kind of
iffy after eating everything my hands
are a bit shaky right now you can tell
in
the camera uh i really need some
nutrients
i don't think i can do this for much
longer if i don't eat something
that doesn't have mountain dew in it
i probably am not going to be feeling
great
i'm going about to go outside for a walk
because i feel like my heart's about to
stop
i don't feel good i feel sweaty right
now so it's been a couple hours since
dinner and i was thinking to myself
man i really want something sweet as if
uh like 80 things of mountain dew isn't
enough sweetness so i've decided i'm
gonna make some cupcakes
and there's a recipe for mountain dew
cupcakes in the book and it's super
simple it takes like 20 minutes all you
do
is take a cupcake mix and mix it with
mountain dew
what could be easier
okay let's take these out it's not the
prettiest looking cupcake in the world
it's small it doesn't rise very much
the mountain dew flavor is really subtle
there's like a tingly
flavor that's the weirdest way to
describe it but that's kind of how it
feels
i have a couple more pimples on my face
than i normally do
i feel like eating this much sugar is
not good for my skin
so now that i've shaved you can actually
see a bit better i'm going to be honest
i looked through that cookbook and just
looking at all the possibilities for
what i could eat for lunch today made me
feel kind of gross
i know it's not super obvious but the
prospect of eating caffeine for
literally every meal from someone who
doesn't even drink coffee
is is having a toll on how i feel on my
energy
i don't feel like i get anything done i
know everyone's gonna be real
disappointed in me in the comments but i
think i need to stop doing this
all the recipes are like meat and
caffeine and this is not something
that's sustainable instead of eating a
mountain dew meal today for lunch
[Music]
hey at least it's green
foreign